allez Florent à deux semaines du début
des vendanges les vignerons touranjo on
le sourire on vous parlait de la chaleur
et du soleil en début de journal et bien
c'est tout bénef pour le vignoble le
raisin mûri et ce gorge dessus à la clé
d'excellents millésime c'est en tout cas
ce qui espère les vignerons de
l'appellation Vouvray c'est 2000
hectares ils étaient rassemblés
aujourd'hui à noiset ou s'est rendu
romain Delphine
moment professionnel solennelle et
symbolique avant les vendanges la visite
de vigne ici sur l'appellation Vouvray a
réuni 150 professionnels sous le soleil
de noiset un ensoleillement bienvenue
après un été compliqué on a eu quand
même une période un peu humide avec un
été un peu juillet-août un peu un peu
bouleversé avec pas mal d'humidité les
plus vieux maître très importantes donc
là c'est très bienvenu pour nous on est
entre 10 et 15 jours du début des
vendanges là cette bonne augure donc on
concentre en sucre on dégrade un petit
peu d'acidité et donc la maturité
s'enclenche et il était temps que du
beau temps arrive cette année la
quantité la grâce à des conditions
favorables au printemps pas de grêle pas
de gel et maintenant des températures
idéales avant les vendanges on dit
toujours que c'est septembre felvin
parce que c'est vraiment la période de
maturation du raisin et qui va
déterminer en fait un peu les profils du
millésime donc certains millésimes à
vouvrait on va plutôt
ramasser des raisins un petit peu moins
riches qui vous permettront de faire
plus facilement des vins de base pour
faire des pétillants et certains
millésimes on va ramasser des raisins un
petit peu plus riches on pourra faire
toute la gamme des vins de base mais
également des vins secs demi-sec et
moelleux au-dessus acidité les voyants
sont au vert en ce début septembre mais
le président de l'appellation fait bien
la différence entre ensoleillement
chaleur et canicule l'idéal si on veut
chercher un truc idéal c'est des nuits
fraîches comme ça votre raisin la nuit
il s'abîme pas et il prend de la
maturité la journée et se reconserve la
nuit jusqu'au temps qu'on le récolte à
l'issue de la visite des vignes la date
du début des vendanges va être
déterminée dans les jours à venir des
vendanges qui devraient commencer d'ici
15 jours et en termes de qualité si les
températures se maintiennent le
millésime 2023 pourrait bien rester dans
les annales du chemin